good what a long climb whoa oh well
you're probably wondering where I've
been all this time
Wow it's a very fascinating story you
see my boy living in vitam or dvd I'm
sure it's happened to all of you at some
point so wait a minute I thought I blew
this place up oh wait no no that was
just a bright flash of white light that
I put down that's right I always get
that and heavy explosives confused wow
there's a lot of assassination attempt
that probably didn't work then well
nevertheless it's good to see the old
girl again and here we are back where we
belong so without further ado I am Groot
didn't hear you come in greetings and
welcome to ask that guy with the glasses
why is it called a hamburger when it has
beef that's a very good question and the
answer is it's a giant conspiracy
against the beef for as we all know beef
in French is buf and of course we're all
aware of Shia LaBeouf
he knew how popular and burgers were
going to be even before he was born so
he tried to claim the name as early as
possible how did he do this you may ask
well how did he manage to star in three
transformer movies that made millions of
millions of dollars some questions will
just never be answered
now let's never mention Shia LaBeouf's
name again unless it's followed by died
today
yes do all Scottish people wear kilts
every single one of them now I know what
you're thinking haven't I seen some
Scottish people wearing pants well
they're very very sneaky that way you
see they take the same fabric as the
kilt cut it up roll it into this pants
like material and then paint it a
different color that way it looks like
they're wearing pants the whole time
when really it was always a kilt not
that there's anything wrong with wearing
a kilt I'm wearing one right now
the Jean version and in case you're
wondering I am going full Scottish I
dyed it red
it looks like the hair from that
princess of brave think about that
tonight
why are you acting so cray-cray oh by
the first krei you mean mass homicidal
in ii cray you mean two small children
because it's fun I think the real
question is why are you not that's right
it's a short answer deal with it I was
working the other day and some guy
passing by gave me a thumbs up
what gang does that represent the
feuding gangs of the Siskel and Ebert
obviously you see System Ebert's rivalry
was so legendary that there were actual
gangs formed from them everybody always
thinks the Bloods and the Crips are
warring because of territory or other
disputes but it's not it's for too dorky
movie critics have you ever seen gene
Cisco's bandanas or Roger Ebert's
tattoos they're amazing I saw them once
but then I was sworn to secrecy never to
talk about it you want to know some
other things I was sworn to secrecy
never to talk about would you like to
know who killed JFK Siskel and Ebert did
you know that the moon landing was faked
yes they just landed on Gene Siskel 's
head and the astronaut was Ebert pretty
much any conspiracy you don't know the
answer to usually comes back to Siskel
and Ebert I know this because I'm making
it up don't tell anybody that it's the
Internet they're liable to believe me
what color is a mirror the color of U+
mirrors don't have colors you fucking
idiot
I suggest you break one and eat it
immediately with onions can you beatbox
of course I can portion Isel if three
people having sex is called a threesome
and four people having sex is called a
foursome then what does it really mean
when someone calls you handsome oh isn't
it obvious
that's when a bunch of hands get
together and had an orgy my hand seems
to do it all the time
isn't that right hand I'm sorry I called
it by wrong name isn't that left hand
he's just shy hiding really nervous
today
come on hand share all your orgy
adventures
he's crazy he's talking to hands why did
the sunshine because he has such a happy
personality
unlike other sons who are just miserable
and dicks like Shia LaBeouf he was
somebody's son once but not anymore
they've disowned him now I know what
you're thinking the Shia LaBeouf jokes
seem very obvious and easy to make
well so are the transformer movies why
do we bake cookies and cook bacon the
same reason we park in a driveway and
drive in a Parkway or wear a pair of
panties but only one bra or Iceland is
green and Greenland is ice how we can
stuff our stomachs but not stomach
stuffing or how my pinky's not pink and
black people are just white people in
disguise you didn't know that one Siskel
and Ebert buy that too no I'm just
kidding it was Helen Keller behind that
one they'll be ever suspect her why
don't we all freeze our diarrhea in an
ice tray and serve mean people drinks
with the shitty ice cubes who says I
haven't that side Internet if you're
drinking anything right now that has ice
cubes in it you know what's really in
there
as a taste good does it does it taste
delicious well that's to be expected and
you can buy my shit anytime you want at
the awesome store calm kids also great
for watering your garden and fertilizing
it all at the same time
shit on the internet because people are
dumb enough to buy it do you want to
build a snowman how did you know about
my plan about regenerating life into
that of a dead snowman I thought all my
research on that was burnt along with
the snowman well let me tell you every
person wants to play God once in a while
maybe even twice in a while three times
okay
I swear I only cure for orphan children
to get this experiment to work five six
if you don't count the one whose brain
that replaced with a dog or two dogs
three okay four but that's my final
offer it's nice doing business with you
where do you see yourself in ten years
bringing to life another snowman do you
have a question my god really nobody's
ever asked me that before huh I'm kind
of caught off guard I mean nobody has
ever bothered to think if I wanted to
ask a question any question and he was
in the world and I can finally ask it I
can finally unveil it to the universe
this question I've always wanted to ask
it just needed somebody to actually ask
me if I could ask the question Oh God we
did so long universe I've waited so long
to put this out there
I'm so excited well I could just burst
um I think that's it I don't think he's
coming back from that one me I was just
so excited
bloom apart kind of downer but then
again she was an awful person so maybe
it's okay
in the end we are seeing hell there is
no more that keV the glasses I don't
think it really makes sense to call it
that guy the glasses that can anymore em
channel awesome tack on some good you
guys yeah okay
em yeah this is history bums saying
there's no such thing as putting two in
the bank that's worth two in the bush
oh there's my home
you